have you seen a lot of movies this past
year I've seen many okay all right so
you make it a rule to try to see you
like yeah absolutely
input equals output so if you're the the
interesting thing is if you want to
write movies I think you should watch
movies I think you should love movies
and you know one of I love movies and so
you know I just came back from Portland
Film Festival where my deal with them
was I will teach classes in the
afternoon as long as I have an
all-access patch to watch movies every
night and so you know you just get to
see a whole bunch of movies that because
it's a film festival you might not ever
see anywhere again and so I love movies
I watched a bunch of movies I when I'm
not you know a paying full price to see
a movie I'm going to the North Hollywood
dollar theater which is actually at
dollar 50 and seeing movies on Sundays
and Tuesdays when they're a buck fifty
and that way I catch up on stuff or
movies that I look at and go not paying
full price for that about 50 yeah I
think for me I don't really care
sometimes who's in a film it doesn't
they don't have to be a big star and but
dialogue is really important for me and
it doesn't feel real and a lot of times
the more dialogue there is the less real
it feels right how do we make a great
scene where it's real it's at like I
just all straight out of Compton it felt
very I haven't seen that yet so I can't
do it I can't do the comment on though
but the general the general thing with
dialogue is the first thing the biggest
problem with dialogue is that writers
often make it carry the burden of the
story when what you want to do is you
want to tell the story visually it's
where screenwriters not speaker writers
there's a reason for that so you want to
tell the story visually and use the
dialogue as icing on the cake once the
dialogue doesn't have is that doesn't
have the burden of telling the whole
story the dialogue can play can be fun I
mean it's still giving us parts of the
story but it's not carrying the whole
story so you know if you look at if you
watch a movie and look at
great movie often great movies have so
much stuff that is dialogue free uh
there the I think it's Billy Wilder who
did this and the story goes to Billy
Wilder who is a great German
screenwriter came to the United States
when the Nazis took over Germany and was
sleeping on Peter Laurie's couch
like many screenwriters Quentin
Tarantino was sleeping on Scotty
Spiegel's couch and Scotty Spiegel got
him a screenwriting job so that he could
get him the hell off his couch
so Peter Lorre wanted to get Billy
Wilder the hell off his couch and hooked
him up but with the Paramount Pictures
and pitched him as the greatest visual
storytelling screenwriter and so they
had a scene I want to say it's in Dodge
Worth but I could be wrong where it was
a 10-page scene where a husband and wife
have a argument and through the argument
we find out that the their relationship
is no longer romantic or emotional in
any way they're just two people that
live in the same house and so there's 10
pages of dialogue and they needed to cut
it down and Billy Wilder turn that into
a half page scene and the half page
scene was husband and wife on the
elevator of their building husbands
wearing his hat wife's got a purse
clutched to her chest doors open
pretty woman gets on the elevator
husband takes off the hat and smiles at
her you know and the wife basically
takes a step away from the husband that
scene gives us pretty much all the
information that the thrill is gone from
this relationship without all that
dialogue and so always be looking for
the scene that can demonstrate what's
going on in the story rather than tell
us through dialogue that doesn't mean
you have to get rid of dialogue but it
does mean that the dialogue can now be
something else can now have fun some of
the keys to good dialogue people want to
have natural sounding dialogue the
problem with natural sounding dialogue
is if you were to go I took a class once
where they said go record people in the
wild so I went to a mall and recorded
people and what I got the most
interesting thing I got was a guy who
spoke entirely in belches and you could
understand him but what happens in the
war in the wild humans in the wild
when we speak we talk and talk and talk
and never get to the point and that's a
problem is in real life real dialogue
seems to never go anywhere so what we
don't want is real dialogue we want
something that appears to be real
dialogue and that means we're going to
craft something so that it sounds real
one of the ways to do that is to have
characters misunderstand each other
because bad dialogue in movies is when
every character knows exactly what the
other character is thinking when they
say that in real life we don't know what
the other character is saying so if you
say I'm sick of your job I'm sick of you
working your job we may hear I'm sick of
you and respond to that we come up with
our response sometimes before the end of
the sentence so misunderstandings occur
in real dialogue and we create that I
have a USA Network movie called hard
evidence which is only memorable because
it was released on video after showing
on USA Network a million times on the
same day as a Julia Roberts movie called
something to talk about both came out
from Warner Brothers and my movie out
rented it in the nation and I have no
idea why except I did also see the Julia
Roberts movie was wasn't all that hot
but one of the things that happens in
that script is it's about a guy who
cheats on his wife and while he's
cheating on his wife his mistress says
she sells medical supplies but actually
what she is is a drug courier and in the
course of the story he she asked him to
carry the gun to their meet because she
usually goes with her boss and don't
worry my boss has been there a million
times the gun always stays in the pocket
never comes out they go to meet do the
exchange and the guy they meet pulls out
a badge and says I'm with the DEA you're
busted and she says shoot him and he
goes shoot him I can't shoot him and she
and basically she says he's just
claiming his with the DEA it's not real
shooting and so she eventually helps the
husband shoot the guy and then the
husband has to go home to his wife and
pretend like nothing happened and so
he's not just covering
the mistress he's now coming up the
mistress and the murder well the white
thinks the husband's acting strange and
decides to follow him and follows him as
he goes to meet his mistress because
he's freaked out about this whole thing
goes to talk to the mistress about it
because she's only one he can talk to he
can't talk to his wife so the wife sees
the mistress puts two and two together
and confronts the husband and says you
know I know that you're sleep in her
confronts the husband says I know what
you did he's like then she it's you're
sleeping with this woman he's like oh
it's only the mistress and so she
basically says you know you're going to
sleep on the sofa from this point on or
you know we're breaking up so he goes
down they get into an argument he sleeps
on the argument he's the one that
cheated so he's sleeping on the sofa and
the wife comes in one morning while he's
in the kitchen and says this is after a
period of time has passed and said that
sofa can't be too comfortable what does
he think she means he thinks she means
you can come up to the bedroom again so
he says so are you saying I can come up
to the bedroom again that's his
misunderstanding
she says no I'm calling my lawyer we're
getting a divorce you got to be out of
here by sundown so by creating that
misunderstanding it seems real so think
about how to create misunderstandings
where one character hears things
different or here's what they want to
hear and then they respond to what they
want to hear and then they get the twist
in there is the reality so dialogue can
now play you know when you when it's not
carrying the burden of the story
dialogue can play dialogue can go down
tangent places characters can say more
amusing things
another thing about dialogue is think
about how dialogue is character based it
all comes from characters and if you
take a different group of people and
have them say things they're going to
say it in different ways and one of the
things that I always use as my example
is I write a lot in Starbucks coffee
shops where all the baristas are dressed
the same they all have the same basic
dialogue what will you be having room
for
Carine etc but each one is an individual
and the spin they put on it their
attitude comes out through the way they
say things so there is a barista at one
of my Starbucks who puts the positive
spin on everything so if you come in and
say I lost my job today she'll say great
you can spend more time with your family
no matter how bad your life is she puts
the positive spin on everything and she
is so upbeat and chipper that I just
want to kill her but but that's her spin
there is a barista who everything is
about himself so if you come up and say
I want you know the tea with two shots
of Melanie goes melons not very good I
like the berry syrup the berry syrups
better with this drink and it's like how
how is Howard's this has become about
you no matter what you say he turns it
into his story and so there are carry
these are these LP all these people have
the same dialogue the same basic
dialogue but how they say it well
they're spin they put on it
it shows their character through you
know the same basic dialogue but the
spin on it and so think about character
think about dialogue is being the
extension of character and how we're
going to learn about that character
through however they say they're you
know the generic line is this now our
job as writers is to take the generic
line and do the specific to character
line you know this character thinks this
this character believes that everything
is sexual if you know what I mean you
know and there's that barista that does
that there's the barista that you know
no matter what you the opposite of the
pepper you know whatever no matter what
you do it's always a terrible day for
them there's the there's the barista
that thinks that everyone's out to get
them it's the paranoid barista it's like
you know so you know why are you asking
about whether we have you know and it's
like all these are different characters
and they come out through basically the
same pieces of dialogue set in different
ways so think about how the character
comes out through dialogue and that
makes it individual and interesting you
know the instead of saying the normal
line we now have the little spin on the
line which makes it a better line the
dialogue
you